e
no problem waiting for others we are
waiting for
you no he said you were downstairs so I
thought we can wait a couple minutes
till you came up the worst ho I've ever
cigarette all right uh with the arrival
of our clerk I think we can get
started I apologize for being
late I understand dependent on an Uber
this morning
yeah um so uh chairman infantine was
unable to make it this morning so I have
the pleasure of chairing the final
meeting of the labor committee for this
term and I had words for him before
left you know he told me that was why he
he didn't come in today
so I'm
kidding of course uh so to start us off
representative Susie would you please
be allegiance to the flag of the United
States America and to the for it stands
one
all representative ORS you are a
do I could take roll real quick
in as we
go why don't we since I just said that
um you could put him in there just call
him after Leno and call me at the end in
case there's a tie to be broken have a
yes what is his name
just
Mark's not here how about anybody else
on your side that's not here let's
see Mason's not
here and grer
not at
each
[Music]
okay all right I think we have our
attendance squared away here so we'll
get started on our
business um as everyone I'm sure knows
we have four bills that we voted to
interim study and now we're here to
address those bills uh just so
everyone's clear on what we're doing
today our vote today will be either to
recommend for future legislation or to
not
recommend
um unlike a bill during the regular
session this isn't a minority majority
report what whichever we vote to do um
we will write a a blurb for the calendar
that explains why we voted the way we
did um I was reminded by our committee
assistant that we close to the due date
for the calendar so whoever makes the
motion and writes the blurb I'd ask you
uh if you're going to handw write
something if you could do it before you
leave if you want to send in something
electronically please um send it to me
as soon as possible um
I guess if you do want to go home and
work on it at night if you can have it
to me by noon tomorrow that would really
be helpful um to make our
deadlines so with that said we'll move
hb17 um this is relative to the notice
of terms and conditions of remote work
Arrangements uh representative Prout you
have a motion I move to not recommend
for future legisl
is there a second second I'm going
to have a
bipartisan uh a representation here and
seconded the um so this is
representative Prout and we'll make this
K
kill and representative proud if you'd
like to speak to your motion thank you
uh I don't really see the need for this
bill or really what what this bill will
accomplish um there's no prohibition
against an employer or an employee
entering into a written agreement for
regarding remote work now uh there's
also no prohibition against in this bill
or otherwise against an employer
changing or revoking a remote work
agreement and this bill doesn't limit
that either not that I would like it if
it did um by forcing an agreement to be
made and written down it kind of locks
in all parties which may not be
desirable um you know part of the
benefits of remote work is flexibility
see I have a laptop in front of me
before the hearing gabbled in I was
doing some work this is just how life is
becoming these days
um and if something comes up that's
outside the agreement now it has to be
edited and reapproved through whatever
process or it's invalid or you're
just the status quo doesn't match their
agreement which can bring in its own
problems and that's just all adding a
lot of work without I don't think an
identified benefit um and so that's a
reason at least uh with what's been
discussed so far we GR in this bill
what's in this bill what been discussed
I don't see why it would be a good thing
to recommend for future legislation
thank you representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and and as uh
my colleague Mr Prout acknowledged uh
and as we had in the hearing way back in
January this is a the thing today so
many people are working remotely and it
is best practices to have an
understanding with flexibility you know
between the employer and the and the
employee that this is what with what
we're doing now and it could change
because this happens or that happens but
it's it's a good thing to talk about but
I don't think we need to legislate it
thank
you representative buudy thank you Mr
chairman um people have been working
remote for a lot longer than we think um
a young lady friend of mine has been
doing it for 15 years for the hospital
she's got a pretty big job and she works
from home never had a problem
my son does work with people all around
the
country he's he's working from home
without a problem his employer just
offered him a a new contract uh and it's
unbelievable so I think when you work
from home is performance Bas either you
do the job or you don't and it's not
like working we all have to work
together and get along and play nice I
think that when you're on your own
you're on your own to either sink or
swim you either do the job or you don't
and um I don't see a need for
legislation on this we're seeing a lot
more of it and maybe down the road we'll
have to do something but I don't think
Now's the
Time thank you any other uh
comments seeing none if you could call
the role representative avalani
yes rep Prout
yes rep love yes rep
ORS yes rep KC yes rep drgo yes rep
parall yes rep barudi yes IED you first
R it sorry
um rep kahill
yes uh acting ranking D sus
yes um rep Bard yes the clerk votes yes
yes 15 to
um write his name
but we'll make it a joint
up all right thank you very much that
was easy let's move along um next up HB
1023 which is relative to requiring
employers to provide notice of resources
available to support veterans with
post-traumatic stress disorder
um and I'll start this off by looking
motion Mr chairman I move not to
second uh representative Drago
okay for the last day I think I'll try
to get it right um do you want me to
comment on this or would you like to
speak it's completely up to the chairman
all right I I will uh introduce this and
if you have something to add
so we held this bill if if uh the
members of the Comm committee remember
because the sponsored submitted two
versions of the bill one in the Senate
one in the house and it was their
preference that they focus on the the
Senate version and and since we hadn't
gotten that yet we thought it prudent
rather than to itl the bill and con
create some kind of confusing message
that we'd interim study it with the
intention that we'd work on the Senate
Bill we did indeed get the Senate Bill
we passed it it has been signed by the
governor um so the reason that I think
we want to not recommend this bill is
that it's already in law and is not
necessary representative avalani if you
have any further is Fantastic Mr
chairman any other
comments represent Broody thank you Mr
chairman I
um I don't remember what was passed by
the senate i
i it's like a couple years
ago as far as I'm thinking but I I
um I um I'm a very active member with
the legion and I know that they were
watching this and um I already told them
that I was going to further recommend
something so I'm going to go that route
um when it comes to Veterans and
especially uh
PTSD um we have some members that have
it and it's always worth looking at as
far as I'm
concerned so the Senate bill to answer
your question was Senate Bill
588 um I what I am not I did not check
word for word to see if it was the two
versions were
identical um I I recall they were
substantially the same at least if not
the same
bill and again
the I think the key Point here is that
we did pass this language in this term
and it has been signed by the governor
and it is law um I understand and your
comment that we can
always look to see if we have further
deficiencies in how we're taking care of
our
veterans
um but in terms of this specific
bill I think the the house has taken
care of it by passing the Senate
version other members of the committee
uh representative paral
thank you so much I do see the Senate
version was amended and many of my uh
concerns about the house bill The Way It
Was Written seem to be answered in the
you um I don't know if it would be
helpful to any of the members
to go into a a bit of detail on on what
was was in the Senate bill and what was
improved about it if I don't want to put
you on the spot but if you have a
further comment members might find it
helpful one particular aspect of it is
that the Labor Commissioner in
consultation with the Department of
Business and economic Affairs and the
office of Workforce opportunity shall
create and distribute to employees a
veterans Benefit Service notice or
poster and the in the house version that
say one would be created here there have
an actual clear path of who's
responsible for that um I don't know I'm
still concerned about posting it uh the
uh
um the penalty for non-compliance I uh I
think probably most your noncompliance
is going to come from this ignorance not
from willful um neglect so I'm really
questioning whether or not we need a
warning system before we start finding
people but this does but I can I'm very
happy with this particular
situation and I will respond to that
members of this committee especially
those of us that have been here a number
of terms recall that in fact uh we
modify the
way labor penalties and the fines apply
so that in the exception of generally
failure to pay wages um any
non-compliance is first addressed with a
warning and only on repeated offense
does it go to a fine sounds reasonable
thank you further
comments representative Susi thank you
Mr chairman um someone who's actually
now serving on the um commission to
study PTSD for First
Responders um I have to agree with um
you Mr chairman that I think the
legislation at this point if it's
already been signed into law I think if
there is an issue later on the bill can
be looked at again the legislation can
be looked at again and it can be tweaked
somewhere but I'm happy happy with the
way it is so I'll be voting in favor
thank
you further
comments seeing none um Madam clerk if
you could call the
role r vanani Excuse me yes rep Pratt
yes RIP love yes rep ORS yes RIP kcom
yes rep drgo yes uh ranking acting
ranking Dem suusi yes
uh rep brudy
no rep Cahill yes rep parall yes rep
bushard yes the clerk votes no repair
yes re St rep stab yes and acting chair
seaworth yes that would be 14 to or 13
to2 all right thank you very much let
let move along to hb1 1226 this is
relative to employment protections for
freelance
motion thank you Mr chairman I move to
not recommend this future
legislation thank you is there a
second representative proud his second
is um would you again like me to start
out by refreshing the committee's me
memory with what this is that would be
um this was a bill that was submitted to
address the situation of what the bill
called freelance
employees um and wanted to extend
to this class of of worker some
protections that
doe statutory
time I think the
committee certainly a majority of the
committee Mo I don't know if it was
everyone um but was not in favor of the
bill to me the the simplest explanation
is that
Freelancers are not employees they're
independent contractors
if a freelancer wants the protection do
an employee they should seek employment
and and then the law covers them I think
there's a concern that if we start to
blur that distinction between an
independent contractor and employee
we're going to
recreate the problems that we've spent
years trying to fix with employee
misclassification the reason we didn't
simply itl this bill is that the
sponsor was asked to work with the
Department of
Labor um to see what in the
existing laws and rules might apply to
the situation and help the individuals
that the the law sought to benefit I
have not heard that meetings took place
but we wanted to have an interim study
to be a a forum if
necessary
um so for that reason I think we didn't
support this bill back in the the spring
when we first had it I think for the
reasons that I just stated it makes
sense to not recommend a future version
representative Susi thank you Mr
chairman so representative Soloman um
advised us that he's talked to the prime
sponsor and there really hasn't been
much work on it so the prime spot pretty
much says that it's not ready for prime
time so we'd support the no further
legislation thank
comment seeing none Madame clerk if you
could call the role rep avalani yes rep
Prout yes rep love yes rep ARS yes rep
culcom yes rep drgo yes acting ranking
Dem Susi yes rep buudy yes rep Cahill
yes rep bashard yes the clerk votes yes
rep Clair yes rep stab yes and Mr chair
yes 15 to
zero very good
let's did I skip you oh no I counted you
oh well okay paral how shall you vote as
you as you addressed yes I apologize oh
that's
okay
you yes how with um the next page we'll
the that was you no you you
did yeah so we'll put your name on it
but I'll
something um last but not least
a favorite of mine this term HB 1597
relative to the maximum weekly
unemployment benefit
amount representative aana you have a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move to
time um is there a
second represent of kahill has
seconded you want to do you want me do
it why don't you say your piece and then
I'll jump thank you Mr chairman turn
your mic on thank you Mr chairman um as
everybody has known um this only deals
with the parttime benefit um that would
allow part-time work before um uh
unemployment wages are reduced uh as we
were looking through the year we had two
bills coming over that were going to
overhaul the unemployment
system and change their ratios and
numbers and we were looking at this
prior to that happening which we
couldn't get the numbers for because we
everything was in flux um I think it
should be looked at together down the
road when we're making changes to the
full unemployment system and then look
at the part-time unemployment system
that way the numbers will work in a very
cohesive manner thank you Mr chairman
thank you and um I will agree with
everything the representative
said I think the to me the motion to not
recommend is not a
um we're not saying that this is not
some not something to be looked at um as
some of the members know I did spend a
lot of time with this I like the concept
but the majority of the committee found
the original concept which was to have
some kind of partial sharing between uh
what the employee keeps from part-time
work and what comes out out of your uh
unemployment benefits check was too
complicated and when we get
complicated we might incentivize things
that we didn't intend to Cen incentivize
so
they committee several of the members
had some simpler ideas that might work
but as uh the representative
explained I don't think it makes sense
to do this outside of addressing
the unemployment benefit as a whole um
because if you make changes to one but
you don't know what the changes are
going to be to the other then you can't
predict the effect um so in writing this
up I think we want to explain that that
the the concept is worth looking at but
in the context of the bigger picture of
and to put it simply we haven't updated
the um the tables that specify how much
unemployment benefit you get for I think
18 years was the number that I remember
and um it really needs to
be looked at again in light of uh what
inflation has
done I think when we sent this to
interim study we fully expected that
there was a bipartisan version that was
going to come through that didn't happen
uh but I certainly expect to see that
work continue in the next
comment seeing none Madam clerk if you
could call the RO rep avalani yes rep
Prout yes rep love yes rep ORS yes rep
kcom yes rep Drago yes acting ranking
Dem Susi yes yes rep buudy yes rep
Cahill yes rep parshall yes rep bushard
yes the clerk votes yes rep Clair yes
rep stab yes and acting chair seaworth
yes 15 to
zero very good and with that we have
completed our business today in near
record time is very exciting um I want
to make one announcement uh before we
all leave for the term as some of you
know I am the representative from the
house to the workers compensation
advisory Council and one of the things
that was discussed during our last
meeting a couple weeks ago now is that
the workers compensation rules are up
for Renewal they they've hit their
5-year period so the department is going
to be working on those uh looking for
things that need to be changed redraft
them um it will then go through a
process once once they come up with
their draft but just a heads up for
anyone here who might be interested in
things um just a reminder that the rules
are derived from
our the laws that we pass so we haven't
made any recent changes to workers comp
so the department doesn't see anything
major that they need to address but
they're going to go through everything
um and clean up any issues that they've
seen
um so with that it
if nobody else has any other
announcements or or business to bring
forward I'm curious to see who's not
running again just so we can say fa well
so let's see a show of hands of anyone
who is not running uh to come back again
next
term it looks like holy cow that's
awesome that is good um so thank you all
for uh your service on the labor
committee we like to joke that it's the
best Committee in the house but we say
that because we believe it um it has
certainly been an honor to serve with
everyone that's here on the committee
and to serve with you in the house I
wish everybody the best of luck in your
upcoming election and thank you very
much I'd also like to thank uh Kristen
in the back our committee researcher has
been very helpful and Jamie is in her
office but she's watching us in the
video so thank you too for for all your
that I will why Bel
labor why labor the point is this a
motion to no you have a comment all
right thank you thank you Mr chairman we
like to to thank uh representative
infantine and yourself for guiding us
through uh the last two years and to the
uh M represent of sus and Sullivan as
well uh for them working with us uh
through some tough issues thank
course representative kill yeah just a
brief shout out to will infant's mother
because I know she's
[Laughter]
watching if there's nothing else I'll
look to do we have we motion to
adjourn so Mr chairman and
seconded without objection we are
adjourned thank you very much